donc ce soir je ne vous appellerai pas
marie laforêt merci vous n'êtes pas en
promotion pour quoi que ce soit vous
êtes ici pour vous exprimer merci
d'avoir choisi d'ailleurs tout le monde
en parle saoulé dire à ce sujet thierry
tout à l'heure vous avez dit
si c'était pas moi ce serait un autre ce
serait pareil je vous dis tout de suite
il savait pas été vous je serais pas là
merci c'est gentil
je vous demande de vous inviter
bien alors il ya quinze jours sur ce
plateau antoine schuller le fils de
didier schuller en compagnie du
journaliste jean paul guillaume est venu
témoigner et d'ailleurs depuis sa servi
à quelque chose parce que depuis didier
schuller est rentré en france et il a
été incarcéré suite à la dénonciation de
son fils de l'actualité d'un vrai [ __ ]
la brève alors effectivement alors la
presse a dit en parlant de la
dénonciation d'antoine qu'ils étaient
manipulés manipulé par jeu spa par les
socialistes pour faire du tort à chirac
on a dit aussi qu'il était manipulé par
vous alors si c'est jospin qui le
manipule on comprend effectivement et si
c'est vous on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi vous l'auriez de
manipuler antoine schouller
malheureusement d'ailleurs et personne
ne peut le manipuler vous avez expliqué
interview vérité
[Musique]
plus
alors la reprendre les choses au début
pour tout le monde comprenne bien vous
avez été mariée avec un ami de didier
schuller qui s'appelle eric de l'avant
des rats qui est un français agent de
change qui vit en suisse lui il avait
été mariée en premières noces avec
catherine hennessy qu'héritière adecco
n'y a qu'ainsi ils ont eu un enfant des
pantins s'appelle diego de l'avant des
rats qui est ami avec antoine schuller
fac était ami avec antoine schuller
comme les deux papas étaient amis alors
on va d'abord commencer par ça parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé dans la presse et
j'aimerais que vous expliquer là dessus
votre mariage avec eric de l'avant des
races s'est pas bien passé très bien
passé il s'est extrêmement bien passé
j'ai eu la chance de tomber sur un homme
courtois intelligent cultivé
gentil et pendant je dois dire pendant
13 ans j'ai vécu un mariage extrêmement
heureux jusqu'aux derniers mois de notre
notre mariage qui a été très
traumatisants extrêmement bouleversant
et où je n'ai strictement rien compris
et ce qui se passait voilà vous pouvez
continuer non je continue parce que
c'est vrai que ça ne s'était pas très
bien passé avec catherine si ça c'était
ça c'est et comme pour moi ça s'est
extrêmement bien passé pour elle a eu
deux enfants donc avec monsieur de
l'avant des rats elle a été je crois
extrêmement heureuse pendant pendant
sept ans et brusquement les choses ont
dérapé pour elle elle a eu un accident
sur lequel elle avait des gros doutes
c'est un accident de moto pour elle ce
sera un accident de voiture pour moi à
partir de ce moment là ses amis
commencent à changer à son égard son
mari l'a dit alcoolique drogué
dépressive dans une secte et dieu sait
quoi et il va tenter de la mettre par la
fenêtre
ce qui fait que catherine m6 partira
avec son sac à main laissant ses deux
enfants derrière elle je suis persuadé
moi même puisque je n'ai aucune raison
de douter de ce que nous dit mon mari
que effectivement catherine m6 est une
folle furieuse donc je vais élever diego
il
l comme mes propres enfants et je les
élève donc en même temps que mes propres
enfants dans une ambiance extrêmement
joyeuse et agréable votre pari a eu un
comportement effectivement un petit peu
bizarre avec vous il dormait avec un
couteau à cran d'arrêt soit table de
nuit c'est vrai nom mais pas il me
montrait le côtoie de fin d'année c'est
vrai qu'il vous prenait le pouls pendant
la nuit pour savoir s'il s'était
présenté une version extrêmement
expurgée des faits tels qu'ils se
seraient passées comme s'en souviendra
peut-être nathalie charron puisque je
faisais une une couverture pour votre
beauté j'ai reçu malheureusement
important de décor sur la figure qu'il
faut à peu près 70 kg en acier et je les
prie juste ici donc hôpital scanner
on termine tant bien que mal interview
les photos que l'on peu de travers avec
un chapeau sur la tête puis tu sais tout
est comme ça et nous rentrons à genève
et là à ce moment là je commence à me
sentir mal vertiges nausées je vais à
nouveau faire un scanner et on demande à
mon mari de ne pas me quitter parce que
je dors 20 heures par jour de ne pas me
quitter parce que je risque de tomber
dans le coma il va se passer quelque
chose de très extraordinaire de 7 heures
du matin à 1h du matin mon mari me
laissera seule sans manger sans boire il
fait très chaud nous sommes au mois
d'août et pendant deux jours d'affilée
ça se reproduit et le deuxième soir je
suis
interrogative et je mime quelqu'un qui
ne bougent plus voir ce qu'il va se
passer et mon mari arrivent à côté du
lit
et simplement il pousse ma main c'est ce
que veut dire cette simple phrase vous
en déduisez ce que vous voulez les
freins de la voiture qui lâche vous
serez très étonnant quand on a une
voiture qui est une ronde du revers
quand on est envoyé en mission à monter
à au festival de cannes et qu'on a pour
mission apparemment de rencontrer
monsieur muhyo et de revenir avec une
certaine somme d'argent dont je parlerai
uniquement devant les juges mais je suis
heureuse de pouvoir le dire à l'avance
devant vous ce soir comme je le ferai à
chaque fois que j'irai voir un juge je
les fais et j'ai essayé de le faire très
souvent pendant huit ans aujourd'hui
j'ai pris la décision de parler d'abord
à la s avant de me présenter devant un
juge de façon à ce que l'opinion
publique française soit au courant de ce
qui se passe c'est une prothèse d'une
certaine façon me protéger je vais vous
dire très sincèrement je pense que
j'aurai une peau de banane qui glissera
sous un camion lequel sera écrasée par
un avion que j'aurai une balle dans la
tête que je serais suicidé je serai très
déprimé mais quoi qu'il en soit
aujourd'hui j'ai enfin la possibilité
après huit ans de dire ce à quoi nous
avons tous à faire face tous ici nous
les français nous avons à faire face à
une organisation
extraordinairement dangereuse et le
gouvernement ne peut rien y faire alors
vous découvrez un jour que votre mari a
pris une assurance vie quand il est le
bénéficiaire si vous décédez vous
découvrez aussi d'autres choses
n'étaient pas tout étaler ici mais enfin
je vous en prie faites le bac il a des
relations homosexuelles avec un homme
politique internationale très connu vous
finissez par découvrir que les affaires
de votre mari s'en sont pas très claires
en fait c'est à dire que je découvre
rien du tout je j'ai tellement la
trouille que je fini par demander à des
gardes du corps de venir et en une heure
je viens mon mari je suis désolé je
resterai pas dans la même pièce que toi
sois tu vas à l'hôtel soit moi je vais à
l'hôtel mais c'est terminé j'ai eu trop
la trouille donc nous séparons très
abruptement il me laisse dans
l'appartement qu'il a mis à mon nom pour
une raison que j'ignore mais que les
juges j'espère comprendront mieux que
moi et je découvre là ce qui était
supposé être les archives de la charge
eric de l'avant des rats ce ne sont pas
des archives ce sont des papiers et en
ville un ordinateur dans l'appartement
notre ordinateur dans un appartement qui
est en mon nom un autre ordinateur
contient effectivement
95 % de dossiers qui lui appartiennent
auquel je ne comprends rien pendant
quatre mois et au bout de quatre mois je
commence à découvrir la vérité et c'est
tout à fait tout à fait est
extraordinaire et abominable on a dix
qui refusait de verser une pension
alimentaire et tout ce que vous disiez
c'était justement pour le forcer à vous
la verser effectivement j'ai demandé
pendant cinq ans il ya une demande
d'annulation de mariage qui a été
instruite cette demande d'annulation de
mariage dans la mesure où on annuler le
mariage ne vous donne pas droit à une
pension alimentaire s'est donc trouvé
que ça n'était pas le but premier au
jour d'aujourd'hui il est bien évident
que comme n'importe quelle femme qui a
été qu'ils divorcent je demande une
pension alimentaire mais effectivement
il ya quelque chose de très spécial je
demande une pension alimentaire élevée
qui est de l'ordre de 30 mille euros par
mois avec un mari qui est annonce
environ 3000 francs de salaire par mois
j'espère avec cette demande que le
tribunal sera suffisamment dans
l'interrogation pour se dire il faut
faire une enquête sur les revenus de
monsieur de l'avant des rats c'est tout
ce que j'espère en mendiant aujourd'hui
pension alimentaire c'est que le
tribunal enquête sur les revenus de
monsieur l'amendé rats et je tiens à
dire au tribunal dès aujourd'hui que
j'ai de quoi l'informer voilà alors ce
qu'il faut lire effectivement c'est qu'à
l'automne dernier quand diego de l'avant
des rats se brouille avec son ami
antoine sous leurs fruits pas du tout il
se brouille pas du tout c'est son père
et ne serait de l'avant des rats qui
disent vous le foot est dehors
immédiatement c'est tout à fait
différent vous le recueillies en dessous
évidemment il est en chaussettes sur le
palier qui serait que je fasse je l' ai
connu tout petit vous lui dites à ce
moment là je dis rien du tout vous lui
dites pas la vérité sur les affaires de
son père et deux de glisse il s'en est
sans doute cela dit moi je suis sur un
dossier de divorce qui est en même temps
effectivement une affaire d'états et non
pas une affaire de pension alimentaire
comme on a bien voulu le dire et je le
lui ai je lui montre mes dossiers parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus qu'avec moi dans
l'ordinateur moi je suis vraiment une
panique totale donc lui commence à
naviguer et d'un coup il a la révélation
absolue qu'il y a comme je le pense moi
même effectivement un une comment voient
une organisation appelons ça une
organisation qui lie à une organisation
criminelle
qui en ce moment a à peu près à sa
disposition deux cent cinquante fois le
budget de la france
j'estime aujourd'hui malheureusement
essai et pas eu envie que ça me tombe
sur la tête et ça m'amuse pas et c'est
pas mes oignons et c'est pas mes
affaires je suis dans une autre vie une
artiste et je n'ai envie de m'occuper
que de ça mais il n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui je me lève pour dire
faites attention vous êtes aujourd'hui
dans un extrême danger alors évidemment
depuis 8 ans tout le monde dit que je
suis une folle une droguée dans fait
c'est comme katherine ainsi et
effectivement ça a été très difficile
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance merci didier
soulet j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire
entendre ce que j'ai à dire c'est pas
pour moi encore une fois que je lui ai
dit c'est vraiment c'est pour vous on va
justement maintenant voir un petit peu
tout ce qui vous est reproché
on vous reproche de fréquenter antoine
soûlard et vous un personnage un peu
étrange un peu ambigu qui s'appelle
christian cotten qui s'est joint à vous
lui dit qu'il est psychosociologue
on le dit proche du mouvement sectaire
on le dit proche de l'extrême droite et
didier schuller d'ailleurs parle de
sectes fasciste européenne en ce qui le
concerne qui est cette question que tu n
es comment avez vous été en contact avec
lui antoine lui qui était toujours sur
l'ordinateur était en train de naviguer
comme on dit sur internet ce que je ne
vais pas faire et trouve un monsieur qui
a l'air de s'occuper très fort de
l'organisation du temple solaire ce qui
s'appelle organisation peut-être que
l'ordre du temple
à huy se trouve que malheureusement je
suis en mesure de donner des
informations puisque j'ai moi même et
c'est mon mari a essayé de m'entraîner
dans cette scène hardcore
donc j'avais deux ou trois détails et je
me suis dit dans le fond ce pauvre
monsieur k l'air de chercher des choses
j'ai convoqué monsieur cotten chez moi à
paris je lui donnais les informations
qui étaient à ma disposition puisque
c'est mon témoignage et que je peux le
prouver et je lui donnais sa merci au
revoir
j'ai dit antoine quand nous sommes
rendrait tous les deux à genève on
arrête là c'est pas la peine d'essayer
avec les français nous avions déjà
envoyé un dossier à la 6ième web via
l'air fou ce que je dis un salaire
vraiment faute à faire alors on veut
soit vous faire taire effectivement
soit vous faire passer pour sa grille
mais avec ce que je raconte mais
sincèrement me raconterait une histoire
comme ça mais je suis la première à dire
maintenant la fille l epic est allé à
temps la vieille chanteuse comme on dit
dans je sais pas quoi elle et elle est
malade elle est en train dragon sauf que
quand même quoi qu'il en soit j'ai une
masse de dossiers qui ne sont pas écrits
par mois c'est bien évident j'ai une
masse aujourd'hui en l'espace de trois
jours une seconde à servir lettre je
voudrais faire parvenir s'il reste des
juges en france du monde me dit kevin et
ce qui est en train de donner sa
démission
on me dit qu eva joly donne sa démission
on a vu que monsieur halphen a donné sa
démission mais dites moi à qui on va
parler nous à moi pendant la terrre ce
que c'était mais ça commencerait alors
antoine sous leur dit lui aussi qu'il a
reçu beaucoup de menaces genre des coups
de fil du genre fallait faire attention
de pas traverser oui en dehors des clous
et on voit que c'est dangereux parce que
lui a dit ça il son père didier schuller
a déclaré si je me suicide faudra pas y
croire le déclarer ça avant de partir de
ça nos matches on voit bien quand même
qu'on est dans un problème mafieux de sa
résidence non pour l'instant lui il est
dans un problème politique mais il est
évident que ce qui s'est passé au et
repérer ou rpr à ce moment là je n'en
sais rien c'est pas mon problème je ne
prenais pas didier soulet et j'en ai
rien à secouer s'il donne chirac pasqua
suçons de problème alors antoine
schuller dit antoine schuller dit que
son père va parler du financement du rpr
et qu'en fait il parlera jamais des
réseaux supérieur qui contrôle tout ça
alors vous vous en parlait pas beaucoup
mais vous commencez à citer des noms
vous citer le nom de l'avant des rares
là on vient d'en parler vous citer le
nom de gobi et le nom de mimran comment
vous des français nous est alors c'est
pas des français bien sûr que sont des
français vient rajouter deux tubes à is
sur
baïse je vais prochain changé non ça
c'est russe accord et morishita ces
japonais je tiens à dire aussi que
bienheureusement et d'une manière que je
n'attendais pas du tout depuis deux
jours à genève j'ai vu au moins quatre
hommes d'affaires extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement important qui m'ont amené
environ 25 kilos de dossiers
ne suis pas seule il y as derrière moi
et autour de moi en ce moment des gens
qui spontanément vous venir dire ceux de
quoi ils ont été les témoins explique l
affaire elf explique l affaire de l'eau
ts sur la base mais s'est excusé c'est
hallucinant histoire c'est fou c'est fou
mais moi ça c'est qu'en fait en fait au
travers de ça on a toute une meilleure
de choses autour en famille bien sûr
mais c'est beau mais cela dit je prends
un risque énorme en venant ici en venant
à dire tout ça c'est que ça ne m'amuse
pas j'ai rien à vendre j'ai rien à le
déshonneur qui les en avaient de quoi
je monte au créneau et je le ferai
incessamment ils ont vraiment fait
n'importe quoi avec mes enfants et ça je
le supporte pas la raison de base c'est
la raison de base c'est la raison de
base tous tous les cinq noms 1,4 à dire
que diego a été du goût de la vendée a
été malade en fait il a eu un cancer du
poumon de deux cancers voilà voilà un
enfant qu'on soigne
27 ans
voilà un enfant qu'on soigne en lui
faisant des piqûres d'hormones mâles
et auquel on donne une somme de 400
mille francs par mois pour avoir accès à
toutes les drogues dont il a envie
quand on l'envoie dans un centre ici à
paris il tombe sur un sur un psychiatre
qui lui dit tu en fais pas beaucoup je
suis franc maçon tu peux tu me dire il
sait très bien qu'il est dans les mains
de son père comment voulez vous que cet
enfant puisse venir à la surface puis
s'est exprimé ce qu'il a à dire puis
sortir de la drogue et du désarroi dans
lequel il est il n'a pas le droit de me
parler mais vous l'avez élevé il est
élevé il n'a pas le droit depuis 94 il
n'a pas le droit de me parler quand il
me parle et à la révolution et didier
schuller montre à paris vous le croyez
ça et j'ai moi mon problème c'est que
c'est louable mais j'ai du mal à avoir
de la peine pour pour ce tome la cua
parce que vous parce que je connais à 12
il n'habite pas loin
de la peine parce qu'il a quatre cent
mille balles perdues mais certes mais
moi non plus c'est pas ça qui me fait
pleurer on est bien d'accord cela dit
son problème reste le même est-ce qu'on
se rappelle quand même qu'il n'ya que 15
% de la pollution de la population
mondiale qui est à toi déjà c'est
exactement pour cela que je me bats si
t'as pas compris que c'est pour cela que
je me parle enfin
de faire péter cette saloperie de 2,2
mafia de merde sur la conjoncture j'ai
un problème un peu mais je peux
comprendre mais c'est pour eux que je me
bats je veux pas qu'on ait la révolution
je veux simplement avertir les gens leur
dit vous voyez bien qu'il se passe des
choses bizarres il ya des gens -
chaussée et ça ça n'a rien eu c'est
repoussé et puis l'hôte et s on n'a pas
pu sont des gens qui se suicident avec
notre balles dans le corps mais on nous
prend pour des cons mais le v vous nom
d'un chien levé vous et les venez dire
mais arrêtez de nous prendre pour des
cons c'est pas vrai il se passe quelque
chose j'ai pas envie d'être là ça me
fait chier mais je suis obligé de le
faire
du contenu
je te rassure un truc que si personnel
bordel de merde c'était marc et la foire
est quand même ouais voilà non parce
qu'il ya quand même un truc on entend
qu'on entend moi qui maritime a quand
même marqué puis je pense la marque et
où les princesses ces juges qui
démissionnent est actée départ que parce
que les bécasses rabou quoi un sens
quand je vais voir les juges ne sont pas
à bourg
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu